vous pensez que votre monde est en sécurité c'est une
illusion profitez de ces derniers moments de
paix maintenant vous avez tous entendu ce qui s'est passé à
Londres mec qui l'a fait
vous allez travailler les meilleurs agents
vos commandants ont commis un crime je
ne peux pas pardonner à
aucun de vous  en toute sécurité,
j'ai attiré votre attention maintenant,
cela pourrait n'être que le début, je
demande la permission d'aller après Starfleet, ce
n'est pas à propos de Vendetta Kirk, peut-être que ça
devrait être monsieur
Jim, vous n'allez pas vraiment après ce
gars, vous n'avez aucune idée de ce que je suis
supposé  faire je sais seulement ce que je peux faire
nous devons le faire maintenant
nous ne rentrerons pas
j'ai l'impression que nous ne sommes pas sûrs que cela se
qualifie
idée de ce que vous avez fait,
je marcherai sur vos cadavres froids
[Musique] a
apporté des armes
alors nous sortons en tirant J'ai dit